welcome back to Fox and Friends is
busloads of migrants continue to arrive
in New York city mayor Eric Adams is
opening Refugee style tent cities and
reportedly begging the federal
government for 500 million dollars to
deal with the surge the mayor ripping
Republican governors in the process
saying quote now more than ever it's
clear that we are again dealing with a
humanitarian crisis created by human
hands while other leaders have abdicated
their moral duty to support a riving
Asylum Seekers New York City refuses to
do so here to react as New York city
councilman Joe Borelli welcome Joe
listen I can understand the frustration
of the people who live in that
neighborhood I've seen some of the the
things that they've had to say
I wouldn't want this Tent City in my
neighborhood park
but haven't the border states for
example
for more than their share
right the burden I mean shouldn't this
be shared it's certainly unfair to to
blame the border states saying they
didn't shoulder enough of this burden
when for years after years whether it's
people seeking Asylum or people coming
here just completely illegally they have
shouldered the majority of the brunt of
this problem and if anything underscores
the fact that it really is a problem
it's the fact that we're Now setting up
tent cities on beaches in New York City
something we do when there's a hurricane
or a flood or an earthquake or something
like that we are responding as though it
is a natural a disaster we're even
looking at a cruise ship to how some of
these folks so this is a real problem
looking at cruise ships as a potential
solution sure it's one of the options on
the table maybe even one of the more
reasonable options we have no idea when
this is going to stop how many people
will come I think the real story here is
how this still was not an issue until
these Republican Governors brought these
folks to Big Blue cities like New York
they brought them to Liberal enclaves
where everyone has a coexist bumper
sticker on their Subaru suddenly it
became a real crisis yeah suddenly they
didn't want to co-exist with the illegal
Americans so this District by the way is
aoc's district
and by the way this district has voted
disproportionately I mean massively for
democrats for Joe Biden's policy so
poetic justice in this it is Poetic
Justice and she shares a lot of the
blames right it's not the Republican
Governor's fault that people are coming
across the border it's our federal
government led by house Democrats and
led by Joe Biden when the Republican
Governors stopped seeing people come
across the border I think that's when
they'll rightfully stop sending migrants
North until that happens we're not going
to see a stop so as a New Yorker look I
want Eric Adams to get Federal money for
this problem I don't want to pay for it
myself but I also think he should be out
there with other Big City Mayors
Governor priscuit even prisca from
Illinois and elsewhere calling on the
federal government to stop the flow of
this migration crisis absolutely it's
also a national security crisis I mean
this is uh just unbelievable I want to
here's a quote quote from a veteran who
lives in that area his name is Bill
Healy 73 he told the Daily Mail First of
all they are not migrants that is what
they are calling them but they are
illegal aliens a hundred years ago
people are talking about the legal way
that they came here through Ellis Island
run by the Army Medical Corps so you
came through America here you had to
have your papers together you had to
have your sponsors you couldn't just
walk in here he is doing what he is
being told by Washington talking about
Adams it is all being dictated and we
don't even know who is running the White
House Susan Rice love this guy look
chances are if you live in that part of
the Bronx your family did come here as
an immigrant from the Caribbean or from
an African country or from somewhere on
Earth and you came here legally and even
you don't want to see these type of tent
cities pop up in your neighborhood I
hope the Democratic party takes pause
from this I hope they do some reflection
and I hope they realize the border is
really where the problem starts I know
that district is very just really
quickly I know that district is very
blue will AOC feel the political Heat
for her role in creating this in her own
District I doubt it that district is so
blue that she's probably safe there but
well then I don't feel sorry for them
Joe Borelli thank you thank you I'm
Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm
Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis